how's it going Brad man welcome back to
San December later 2030 so there's a new
update with the [ __ ] weather but is
it space maps what did we got for 9 for
a Florida
don't forget to code what is going on
here I wonder what's inside hope there
would be like a huge vagina or something
oh boy was it eight oh my god I'm a
genius
yeah all right what do we got in here if
I like that X X Files whoa whoa whoa are
you why are you slapping yourself bro
come on why he's like I'm stuff fine but
I'm so fabulous this it looks pretty
[ __ ] dead to me anyway yeah it's not
like he's gonna make it out I mean of
course he's gonna make it out
I am dr. Pierce anyone fabulous shall
live what how can you die what a [ __ ]
let's pink your finger that [ __ ] let's
see it always sounds perverted when I
say it I don't know why
perform a pewds ball all right I'm
touching you on the inside all right
here we go it's all or nothing here
breath we're gonna do a [ __ ] pills
ball if it's the last thing I'll ever do
don't panic
how do we get the ball out ah that's if
not Vine good pills bolt penetrate just
like a real life for nine but far up for
a I'll slap you here comes yes really
really paper glue and I should do it
alright I'm done here
there we go Oh disgusting [ __ ] heads
ma pits but yes pips ball high five
well this is awkward it's first they
must get yeah yeah have a snack once
yeah
yes now what's next oh [ __ ] he's dying
how do I get the pills fall out
I don't know why are you bleeding so
much
why am i aboard I don't make sense n n
eat my balls okay hold it for me please
I guess not okay well let's get the
Cherie oaken yes yes this should do it
I'm cutting myself like an emo oh god
how could this
my
got nowhere
come on baby come on
pits ball pits ball pits Bop pet spa job
not value a stinky butt would have
thought - - pills balls in okay this is
a signing really weird I'm gonna call
you a Christina Aguilera because you
just look alike I'm gonna give Christina
my Pierce ball and don't read into that
if you die on me I'm gonna kill you and
then that's not a joke I'm serious
I will [ __ ] oh [ __ ] sorry it's I that
was a joke we're good Christina we're
good Christina I like you I like you
better when you're not singing what I
need a scalpel
Miranda where is that [ __ ] when I need
her Wow my balls are being a real [ __ ]
right now why why Matt yes yes the other
one the other one the other one yeah
just the ball is free
why do you resist
desperate times comes desperate
I can't even grab tough hog in an
affinity head awesome thought well it's
a Jeff yeah
okay okay okay shut up it's not even
difficult when a man wants his pig balls
he will get his pits balls and I can
assure you that his terrible joke
instead of oh my god
oh my god let's rip off his alien deck
ah that's what you get Christina
Aguilera I'm sorry they teach you this
in school come on penetrate
what what kind of school do you go to I
don't [ __ ] know it's right there
I don't understand how balls work I
don't understand
Naruto Naruto
not even a rota getting a dabbler I
don't even care just luckily I gotta
care just give me my goddamn pills ball
and I'll be on my way sir
Pitts ball oh my
is it off it is off okay now get your
[ __ ] hands out of man stop dancing
stop dancing
No shut up huh
don't burn nipples if you don't have to
the smart my mama always said when I
grow up
okay I'm burning nipples even though I
don't have a job down the cube
what-do-i-do what-do-i-do what-do-i-do
dildo if all fails grab the dildo come
on open your mouth Christina you're used
to this come on there you go
just please work I never asked dildos
for anything but right now I sure as
hell never trusting a dildo again give
me the pills Bob gave me the [ __ ]
pills spot are you [ __ ] with me how
is it even it's not it doesn't matter
magically makes sense
see yes I'll see you I'm so [ __ ] get
out of here alien penis see I'm so
[ __ ] good at this like I need an
Oscar ball it's like his brain just like
every guy ever come on this is our
moment
mom what the [ __ ] okay okay yes
this guy ah bud slam-dunk mother [ __ ]
ass get in there oh okay Oh God pills
ball that's how we do it that's how my
balls out of place
thank you sir I rest my case and that's
it hope you guys enjoyed watching leave
a like if you did it subscribe come
birthday see you